he's a drew brees the saints quarterback
joining us on the show we've been
talking about this for for two hours now
on and off the difference between being
an all-star and all pro and being a
superstar do you have a definition of
what a superstar is in sports I don't I
don't I just uh I just play the game and
let you guys talk about that kind of
stuff but you're one but if I said look
at look at basketball and tell me what
would be a superstar let's take it out
of football now I consider you a
superstar in football so you already in
a neat because i think it's winning I
think it's marketing consistency
household name so you check the box on
all those so i would consider you and
brady peyton manning you know just some
of the guys who were considered super
stores but if you were looking at let's
say the NBA what what would constitute a
superstar for you well I I'll kind of
aggregate I'll take it a step further I
think uh I think when you say superstar
you say this guy has the ability to do
something every time I turn on the TV so
we'll say the NBA that maybe I'm gonna
see something I've never seen before
right or maybe this guy is gonna this
guy's a game-changer like he has the
ability to to do something that nobody
else can do that would be I'd be my
definition is Odell Beckham a superstar
then because we're not sure what we're
getting and he does things that nobody
else is doing or is it too is it too
early to label in that well well you
could say superstar potential okay yeah
I mean I I think he's I think he has all
the potential in the world to be a great
great player and obviously you you see
those flashes those moments by some of
the plays I EDT SP catch from last year
but you know I mean he's only a what a
second year this will be his third
season right so certainly he's on that
path you know but to your point you know
consistency and being able to do a time
again over a long period of time I think
that's something that probably falls in
that category as well would you rather
have a speed rusher or a great
quarterback on your team um well a pass
a great pass rushers and make up for a
lot of deficiencies other places right
if what would you rather face a speed
rush or a great core ok I'd say there's
if if every if everybody's open but the
quarterback can't get the ball off well
that's where yeah right right if not
even the best corner of the best cover
guy in the world can cover somebody for
longer than four seconds so if the
quarterback has all day back there he's
gonna find somebody eventually if you
can't get home I with what happened with
Brady yesterday I wanted I'm glad you
were coming on because I don't know is
there any comparison with what happened
with Bountygate and what's going on with
the Patriots and Brady I I don't think
so I don't think so and here and here's
why because I think you have to you have
to take a look at the environment as to
what was happening with the league back
when that whole Bountygate thing came
about the league was under such pressure
about player health and safety they were
getting hammered about their negligence
in regards to reporting the information
that they had about the long-term
effects of head and neck injuries and
just the whole this was right in the
middle of all the concussion lawsuits
and a lot of the untimely deaths of so
many you know former players because of
the effects of all of those injuries and
so in the league needed they needed
something that showed that they were
taking a very firm stance in regards to
players health and safety and so it was
kind of a perfect storm where they had
the opportunity to lead
investigation against the saints but
kind of with a predetermined result you
know nobody got to see any of the
investigation nobody got to see any day
supposed facts of that case it was just
tears here's what we here's what
happened here's the punishment and
that's that and I think what they didn't
what they didn't Bank on was the fact
that guys like Scott Fujita who is the
most one of the most high character guys
there is being a former teammate and a
great friend of mine you know ends up
ends up fighting that and Jonathan Vilma
ends up fighting that and at others and
at the end of the day all those guys
were vindicated you know but
unfortunately the you know the damage is
done you know their reputations that
took a hit and and and the perception is
that there was something going on just
because that's what the league drove
down your throat with it and at the end
of the day was found that it was much
different than what the league said um
but they had to do it based upon the
environment that they ran with player
health and safety you know this this is
much different because this has you know
there's again it's league-led
investigation where nobody myself you
the public nobody really gets to see the
facts of this case everything's kinda
behind closed doors everything's
internal and yet here's the punishment
and and that's bad and that's why this
unilateral decision making you know uh
you know ability to give punishment by
the commissioner is is really unfair I
think that there should be other people
that are involved in that process and at
the end of the day if there's
disagreement then there's a third party
neutral arbitrator who has the ability
to come in and resolve those situations
um but instead you're never going to
have a trusted system you're never going
to have a trusted system when nothing is
transparent its unilateral it's judge
jury and executioner handed down by the
commissioner trust me this is in the
best interest of the league this is you
know you know all the sound bites that
come out of the league office when it
comes to player health and safety or
when it comes to you know these types of
decisions that are made where
you know we as players based upon the
facts of things that have happened
previously with Bountygate and other
other instances where we just know that
that's not that's not the truth that's
not the case and we need any more fair
process is Brady a pawn in this well I
mean you know I I I think the proper the
the the part of this that i mean i i i i
don't know about you but i thought this
was a dead issue you know when this pops
up two days ago is like whoa you know
where this come from all this seems like
it's kind of been happening behind the
scenes certainly I never I I thought
that this was resolved you know going
back to last year and obviously it
wasn't just here it is kind of rearing
its head again but the end of the day I
think that is forget the issue that's at
hand here with you know deflategate or
whatever you want to call it I think
this is an issue again with the fact
that the commissioners all control and
authority was challenged and you know
the league is going to do whatever they
can to make sure that people know that
he is in this position to you know
basically make these types of unilateral
decisions and there's nothing anybody
can do about these drew brees of the
Saints joining us what's your contract
situation it's all going it'sit's kind
of the homo contract process where there
really is no deadline you know I think
usually when it comes to contract
situations I think people are motivated
by deadlines and really is no deadline
of ish so it discussions are ongoing
you'll you'll know as soon as I know I'm
sure but I mean bottom line is this i
have so much trust and confidence in our
organization and my future there and i
think it's only a matter of time I just
don't know when it's going to be you'll
retire a sink that's my plan yes
absolutely over the age of 40 I would
like for it today yes I got you'd 60,000
your
right now how important is like what
number is important is there any number
that's important all cheering have it
that's not what motivates me um I don't
have a number yeah number rings would be
nice yeah you know you uh 500 listen
again there's no number there's no
number that motivates me touchdowns
yards none of that stuff um the the
challenge the opportunity the blessing
to play this game every year and to do
it at this stage in my career um to do
it in front of my kids who are now
getting to the point where they they get
it a net school you know they come to
the games they like their die hard they
love that Superdome atmosphere I mean I
get to share these moments with them
that that makes me want to have a last
forever I know you have a product to
enlighten us on tempur-pedic so i'll
give you the microphone here the
platform is yours i well today we're
we're launching the breeze on breeze
campaign which is my relationship with
tempur-pedic i've been a tempurpedic
owner for one a decade now so it's
always fun when these topic types of
opportunities come together that are
super authentic where you know I I am
claiming that they named the temper
temper breeze line of hmm mattresses
after me even though it's spelled
different I'm just believing that
because I've been such a fan and owner
for a long time but the bottom line is
it's a new line of mattresses with
cooling technology in it for all of us
who sleep hot especially my offensive
linemen like max Unger who I had the
chance to shoot a series of digital
videos with surrounding new temper
breeze with cooling technology mattress
where I basically break into his room at
three o'clock in the morning night
before game and have him sleep on the
temporaries mattress because he's
sleeping hot and then he cools down and
he goes out and place lights out the
next day so again we know it's not about
the quantity of sleep it's about the
quality of sleep and I've always
believed at pepper pedic gives you the
best quality sleeper for more
information tempur-pedic calm / breeze
BR e z e good luck with the contract
talks always great to talk to you thank
you drew and you too Thank you Thank You
breeze the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience